beh ma quando milano campagna che
l'apertura bella tutti ragazzi di minuti
a questo momento io sono un po dice che
lui e giorgio stiamo studiando ragazzi
perché dobbiamo fare una sfida di ballo
se noi noi siamo capaci fare le cose ma
io faccio la donna le carico sono nato
cranico io donna un uomo to momento
donna non abbiamo scambiarci capito
questa pubblicità delle palle sismi di
paesini vuoi come vuoi
vorresti portarmi a letto bene e male
pasta quanto miei nostro ci si prende
leggi sempre io faccio così colpire
donne siamo single tutti e due ma ogni
occasione migliore per trovare il
ragazzo giusto pensato di certo l'aria o
se mia madre vede questo video sono
nella merda ma basta se compri pure
questo dovrebbe essere fatto una ragazza
per avere tre teste sì certo che molti
dei siti per tremonti no no no no no zio
dai ragazzi di chi aveva fatto punteggio
nei kg ha fatto sto gioco col topo gigio
quindi se che ho bisogno di andare in
ferie non è stato cos'è sta roba
non dimenticando mettere questa cosa io
devo a cristo quanto viene se coulter
ogni altro settore
volete mica mezzo mondiali sono
l'organico tranquillo abili in dignità
prima di cominciare mio cane o 10 ha
picchiati barak in quanto sia meglio buy
in iniziale io sono stato sei verde le
slot ma che ci siamo tutti carichi a
bomba per comune sono si muove dove kg
chi sono dove anche cantare i topi punti
[Musica]
ma siamo per essere umano che lo risolve
se lei mi chiama facciamo canale sempre
sveglia con la palma non vengano posso
fare io ormai sono di affetto che sia
facile la famiglia che bella botta a me
la sento io stazione manzoni che la
[Musica]
prendo io sono scheme di farlo non
rischi di ballo
[Musica]
non così le sciocchina vivere contavamo
sul palco sono già in campo stupida
nessuno ancora una stella
ecco come adesso basta famiglia finisce
sta canzone d amore
basta molto molto calzatura non posso
finora preso noi era come sono fatto
niente se al tema spaventati da battere
è finita due starebbero preparandosi
appelli e bellissimo proprie battaglie
che siamo in falso
tu che stai correndo questi video hai
trovato gli uomini giusti per te questa
cosa la condivido la faccia della sua
mamma quando la tua vita è triste
ricordati che noi siamo qua da questi
video rari con l'amica una volta stavi
peggio nell'ultima l'ultima l'ultima dai
ma anche questa vicenda ci sono serate
che adesso si è sentito con tacchetti
[Musica]
forte ma le prendo io non ho giocato
male come fatto il cappello il cappello
[Musica]
prendete facendo bene ma cosa farai pace
mi chiamo il radar e bellicosa devi
essere pronto
sei pronto signori si scusarono il
cappello
3com e sono michael per festeggiamo il
cartellino ma da chi sa cosa che ti
stimano vorremmo andare gioco sporco
dove ragazzi è stato il tutto è quanto
dignitoso prima di tutto spero che vi
sia piaciuto le camere siamo stanchi
dobbiamo buttarci nel freezer scoperto
perché ha aperto solite roger aveva
fatto da solo
i ragazzi spero che il video vi sia
piaciuto come sempre piaciuto al momento
è un mi piace anche a pagine di facebook
e coerente nella descrizione che
telecomando in un enzo lo perdo sempre
grazie ciao ciao fischiatemi ci
clicchiamo lo prossimo video è la
ragazzi